oh just a scratch yeah that's nothing
the stab wound has actually to benefit
it's an old Native American trick what
do you mean let me learn you a little
bit about the Indian to Kenny the crow
you should private a way to build
themselves elaborate teepee complete
with all the trimmings buffalo hides
their journey shellac squirrel and what
they would do they build a shitty little
tepee right behind it still wet yeah
they would live in a shitty little
teepee uh-huh now whenever people came
to rob them they'd always go for that
nice to eat me
that's one of the crow wood and wasn't
from the back what hey how you feeling
oh you look great
we're gonna do some night training today
go on and get on the speed bag see you
hit up nicer that's that old pro
technique
and pumps and kidney blood purplish
purpose he's developing too real fighter
yeah my night may be a night of
reckoning well if you church at will
make his debut that's forever change the
face of box tomorrow night
Kenny spec I'll go knock somebody out
what's the truck